let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
happy
happy hump day
u.s soccer
gets into a collective bargaining
agreement that gives women
on the u.s soccer team the exact same
pay as men they will divide it up
equally great news other great news
madison askwatch cawthorne
will be known from this day forward as
the former boy or maybe
maybe maybe we should call him the
former the former cuck i don't know
i don't know
it seems to be
and a lot of people are asking the
question out there are marge and bobo
next to lose show
episode 142 we have some special some
special stuff for you today we have an
interview that we recorded over the
weekend from dakota von adams the
estranged son of the oath keeper's
founder
stewart rhodes
he joined us on saturday for some of the
updates on stuart rhodes
news of course since then there's been
more stewart rhodes news he was in court
yesterday uh scott mcfarlane had tweeted
uh a play-by-play of stewart's court
hearing
and at one point he describes how stuart
rhodes is clicking away
on a laptop
hmm
and i surmised what
is stuart rhodes typing hmm what would
stuart rose be typing what would stuart
rhoads be looking at on a laptop during
his court hearing
what could it and shall it be
the the judge
in scott's reporting showed that the
judge was not open to the idea that we
they must they must find a different
venue than washington dc the judge
wasn't buying that argument just like
they haven't bought the arguments
anywhere else it really is kind of funny
after reading scott's reporting from
inside the courtroom with stewart rhodes
sitting there and stuart rhodes's lawyer
is trying to make the case
that that the insurrectionists the
people who are trying to overthrow our
government in the name of donald trump
helping donald trump commit the cheeto
dust kangaroo coup and the attempt
to [ __ ] on our constitution and tear it
into p as donald trump most
spectacularly does all the time
apparently
in that effort
they think that there's been crimes
committed against the residents of dc
and that they will be bias
against the insurrectionist
that's the lawyer's arguments like look
the victims here in all of this are the
residents of washington d.c
because
of the of the crimes committed
i mean
it's it's the crime is against all
americans it doesn't matter what [ __ ]
venue you go to
these [ __ ] boneheads trying to
overturn our vote
regardless of who you voted for they
tried to not certify and not seat the
the proper president of the united
states on january 20th
and brian ulrich
one of stuart rhodes's lieutenants
admitted in court to the judge that
their plan was to make sure that there
was not a transfer of power
a peaceful transfer of power
that was their mission that was their
plan
so we are going to ask uh stuart
rhodes's estranged son dakota von adams
today
in an interview so we will play that
here and here about a quarter into the
hour here
uh it's a good it's a good long
conversation so stick with us after
after the interview we will surf the
tweety tweets and the trinity trends
because boy
do we have some video for you there's a
ton of video from yesterday
from all the trump losses that ensued
now i don't know if they've decided some
of these races now some good news is is
that it looks like the democrat some of
the democrat primary races are being
decided this morning which is good we
can get that uh behind us get the get
the actual candidate in place
and start working towards a democratic
win in some of these uh key senate races
like pennsylvania and ohio so now we
know that tim ryan is a democratic
candidate that will be on the ticket
in ohio that is he is the pro-democracy
candidate
and it seems that fetterman
even with some of his health issues
pulled out a win in pennsylvania so now
the weight of the pro-democracy movement
in this country has to get behind the
pro-democracy candidates which are ryan
and fetterman in that region in ohio and
pennsylvania in those key critical
senate races and let me tell you
something if you're pissed off out there
in pennsylvania or ohio you're [ __ ]
pissed off at joe manchin nothing should
drive you more to the polls because joe
manchin won't won't carve out the
filibuster for voting rights he won't
carve it out to codify roe v wade he
won't do it that should piss you off
enough that should give you enough
motivation
and show that [ __ ] strategic outrage
to count by voting in the general
midterm this november for the
pro-democracy candidates to make sure
that we can box out joe manchin in the
senate if that's what you want that's
what you're pissed off about
regardless of where you fall on the
political spectrum
you know i know i don't care if your
you're way left you're a leftist you're
a liberal you're a socialist you're
democratic socialist you're a radical
commie i don't give a [ __ ]
what you are if you're in the coalition
a pro-democracy where you want to make
sure that the democrats have a majority
where they can carve out for voting
rights
and they can carve out to codify roe v
wade
then you must go vote for those
pro-democracy candidates you must you
have to
you have to encourage your family your
friends your colleagues your church
members your community members
to vote pro-democracy in november
and here we are we know who we are going
to vote for
that's that's that's what we have
so stop stop the [ __ ] don't be
[ __ ] oh this democrat that democrat
and this is who and i lost get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
if you concentrate on too much on who
won what and how much and all that
[ __ ] we've got that election's done
it's counted it's done it's behind us
let's move on to the next important
election which is the midterm in
november
and the most important part about the
midterm in november is to make sure we
have enough in the senate that joe
manchin is irrelevant do you want joe
manchin to be irrelevant do you want him
to be
irrelevant pro-democracy person out
there that's who i'm talking to
you live in pennsylvania you live in
ohio you must go vote for the
pro-democracy candidate then that is
what you must do
we are on the same pro-democracy team
now you may disagree with this or that
or here or there
but you must you must agree that our
democracy is at stake
we cannot let fascism win and continue
to win so if you're upset if you're
upset
about little joe manchin in west
virginia do something about it in
pennsylvania and ohio do something go do
something the one thing you can do is
use your ballot as your strategic
outrage and encourage your friends your
family your colleagues your church
members your community members to do the
exact same thing
get off your ass and let's do this [ __ ]
because we can folks we can we have
before we did it eight million more
votes for joe biden look
81 million people i agree
i agree with all the trump pumpers when
they say
81 million people didn't vote for joe
biden of course 81 million people didn't
vote for joe biden
81 million
voted
against trump
i mean i'm sure there's some that are
that really thought that joe biden would
be a good president
that really thought he would work for
the country work for the common working
man
the unions and he's shown to do that
he's shown to be a president for the
people for the unions not for corporate
america
and to protect our interests here at
home and abroad he's shown that he is
willing to do that and he is willing to
go to the fullest extent to protect
democracy that's important but 81
million people didn't vote for joe biden
a large large large portion of those 81
million votes voted against trump
that
is
the facts
and we have to continue
our beat back of fascism in this country
we have to continue
and continue and continue and continue
we are on the team of pro-democracy
forget about our differences for a
minute forget about the policies for a
minute forget about line items and bills
that don't exist
forget about that the only thing that
matters
is that we protect our democracy now
today this year
that is what is at stake
you want to cancel student debt you want
to have children start school at three
instead of five do you want
do you want to not go broke because of a
medical bill do you want to make sure
that college is affordable that housing
is affordable you want to make sure of
all that stuff
that your doctor bills are affordable
you can afford to go to the doctor
do you want all that
well let me ask you do you think the
republican party is going to deliver
that any of that to you any
this fascist republican party
do you think they're gonna give you to
make sure that you have liberty over
your bodily autonomy do you think
they're gonna
do you think they're gonna not ban math
jesus christ they're banning math
they're banning math
in florida they're trying to marry
children in tennessee and missouri
they're trying to ban condoms in states
so
are you pro-democracy are you not
pro-democracy
let's do this
and let's show these [ __ ] who
we are and what we stand for just like
we did in 2020 we can do it in 2022 and
as soon as we're done with 2022 we go to
the next important race to fend off
fascism the next one
take it to the house
so
i appreciate all you being here oh my
gosh we have so many this morning
so many new listeners you guys know we
broadcast every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific
thank you midas lisa
uh lisa says damn i haven't been able to
be on here in a while so many new names
hi tony good morning my desk lisa we're
glad to have you back thank you for the
super chat
we have we do have so many new listeners
here it is crazy the books of face
the youtubes the twitch the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends
you guys are coming every single day
chris n is here chris good morning
christina's here andrea's here cynthia's
here suzanne's here uh debbie from salt
lake is here
uh we have megan patty kimberly carlin
uh debbie nancy holy moly it just gets
better up midas
minus margie midas
margie i want to let let's bring in
let's bring in gabe sanchez here uh gabe
uh we've been getting this name
incorrect for a while and i i want to uh
i want to apologize
to to midas margie and i believe if she
can give us a uh
if she's listening still she can give us
a thumbs up in the chat i believe i
believe that's uh
we've been messing that name up for a
while
and well you have to forgive me i i and
gable attest this i'm horrible horrible
yeah horrible at night yeah you stay in
school guys you know make sure
dropout so this is this is this is maybe
more of a reason to advocate for
education i guess it really is you know
i i think as as we should we should both
be pushing for education you don't have
to go to you don't have to do higher
education like go to college if you
don't want to but you should you know
read books and you know solve for the
inequality that is crt right right yes
absolutely even even even books that are
banned you should read those
yeah you should ban i mean well most of
them i mean you know you read what you
want you should have the freedom to read
whatever you want and make the decision
on your own
just like women should have the freedom
and right to do whatever they want with
their bodies right and don't let anyone
else tell them what they can do or they
don't do you know we always we always
talk about on here about um these
fascists trying to hold us back but did
you hear about the us women's soccer um
the collective bargaining agreement that
they can't reach this morning the equal
pay right yes right did you hear this uh
which is a step forward um towards women
at least on the u.s soccer team uh
getting their equal pay and i believe
the way that it reads um that they're
actually going to break up the pay
equally between all the players whether
it's male female as long as it's u.s
soccer they are going to share those
uh those that that pay scale i guess it
were
equally which is a good thing like
that's the way we should be headed in
this country
and and i think the country is headed
that direction that's why these these
fascists are so hell-bent on trying
every which way they can to convince
people to gaslight people that we should
be going the opposite direction because
they're terrified they're terrified of
of women having rights and equal pa what
what are they so scared of what in the
[ __ ] is going on why in the hell do they
hate women so goddamn much and i'm sure
we'll have a lot of bad takes on this
u.s soccer thing oh
totally yeah yeah there'll be some good
why should we pay them the same amount
it's like dude you want to go run up and
down a field for uh 90 minutes
i guarantee you could not larp your fat
ass up and down that field and compete
with any of the women to the caliber of
skill and the lettuces that they have so
right right
it broke between your keyboard shut the
[ __ ] up it's it's gonna it's gonna be
funny to watch a bunch of guys who who
couldn't run who couldn't run a
20-minute mile oh
to talk about how bad women are are much
much worse at soccer than men and they
shouldn't get paid as much and
uh dudes dudes you don't even have the
energy to watch them play soccer a
little while uh we do okay she she just
showed up
oh okay get it thank you for having my
back she's talking to mj yes we said it
right right i just want to make margaret
if we didn't please correct us
margie
marky
is that it can we get confirmation i'm
we're going to wait before we move any
further i think she's giving us blue
hearts here i think we got it right okay
all right all right cool cool we we
apologize and it's mainly me it's mainly
me let's face it it's hillbilly over
here no yes no oh mj says no no okay is
it my god
no
mar
so did we say before we said it right
before margie no margie
i don't know guys how i do i want to i
went to college and i can't figure this
one out
i've got two different degrees i can't
figure out something for that expensive
education there [ __ ]
so much
so we said it right before rg margie
so i was saying it correctly okay i saw
i thought i saw a message in it
e yeah they're saying yeah yeah just
said it
dave accused me the other day oh my god
you should have heard this conversation
he's like look
look tony
look tony you're saying names wrong i
say names wrong all the time sometimes
i gotta the reason i bring it up because
i got an instagram message from mine is
margie and i thought i read it
differently but i apologize
anyway
more anything i said yeah do not listen
to anything gabe says
hey did you hear did you hear there is a
there's a guy
in north carolina um i don't know this
ain't hard g okay you know what i don't
know anymore listen
there's a guy in north carolina and um
this guy in north carolina
he liked to lie a lot he he had this
thing about i don't know some something
about sex cocaine orgies or something
did you hear about this guy i think he
lost his race are you
are you talking about uh
the trump humping
cousin thrusting yeah tree punching
mm-hmm
one time one time one-time loser
yeah yeah yeah that guy okay yeah i i i
think we should call him from here on
out the former boy
um yeah he is the former boy the former
boy the former boy or i we could test
out the former cuck i mean that's
probably well i mean once a [ __ ] always
a cuck you know right yeah it happens it
happens uh but
yeah madison cothorn you know
sealed here
i said last night
it's almost like now he was a shitty
person before this right
and
i want to say that it's almost like him
running for public office
made his life even worse like it ruined
his life because you got to think like
there was the whole naval academy and
there was the fight there was the uh
there was the accident that it got in a
car with and obviously becoming
paralyzed
and
in that scenario he would you know in
sexual predator like these were all
things he did before however once he
started running like all candidates
everything comes to light and all
becomes public right so it was like oh
he lied about getting into naval academy
he lied and tried to sue his friend with
a car accident he was a sexual predator
he did all these other things in the
privacy of his own or public because he
was on the royal caribbean cruise with
lingerie or the privacy of the hotel
room with his cousin like all these
things now begin to come up they bubble
up to the surface
none of this would have been an issue if
he never had actually run for office if
he had never actually put himself out
there and said i'm gonna be you know i'm
a constitutionalist i'm a history nerd
i'm this i'm that it's like dude you
crossed the wrong person
you better hope that all of your [ __ ] is
unlocked because if not
i i think i think he's done i think he's
oh yeah i actually i actually
at this point to just resign his seat
and
and
uh i mean listen he [ __ ] around and
found out and he did it to himself
and that's what and like all these
things again well he did it to his
cousin too well yeah he did it to his
cousin obviously
whatever that was i'm not sure
but
yeah
the the reason
that he is in the situation he's in
right now is only because of himself
obviously you know the gop helped kind
of push
the blackmailing and the exposing of him
and all this and that
um
but yeah the guy is uh if you want to
read about it there's stuff on him being
a sexual predator there's stuff on him
lying about being in the naval academy
there's oh there's all kinds of
insurance about this
yeah it's it's insane oh but yeah
madison carthurn did it to himself
absolutely and that's one of the main
reasons when we when we made the video
of him humping his cousin we're like oh
what face you put on there and me i was
like oh gotta put his own face because
he [ __ ] himself right right that's
that is that is a good
a good visual um the video that we did
if you want to see it go go to our our
podcast twitter account at
tonymichaelspod uh you will see you will
see the uh
the uh
the video there yeah the infamous video
tony was like we got to put a face on
there and i was like i know exactly
whose face to put
thank you thank you again uh for the
super super chat minus margie i guess is
what i don't know more i mean i i do i
do know i do know that i'm going to call
askwatch
askwatch uh the former boy from now on
so the former boy the former boy the
farmer i'm a real boy nope
you're the former boy he is the farmer
boy he is the former gabe we we had a
great conversation
uh with dakota adams the estranged son
of stuart rhodes the founder of the oath
keepers who is uh currently um
being detained and he had a hearing
yesterday
um i i guess uh so we saw he said
capture typing away yeah he was typing
on a laptop which is um i don't know if
it was like a copy of hunter biden's
laptop that he had there um that he was
trying to research you know do his own
research to figure out what's on that
laptop or not i would imagine uh you go
to
my my twitter feed and you can see where
i typed out what is stuart rhodes typing
and there there were some good answers
and i think dakota and even tasha adams
his estranged wife um left some answers
there in that thread so you go look at
that but dakota this interview that we
had was before this hearing um but it
was some of the news with some of the
new plea deals and some of the
indictments that are coming down
um and also the news of text messages
being revealed
where
roger stone
excuse me uh stewart rhodes possibly
possibly was using
what maybe roger stone as a liaison to
try to figure out when martial law was
called um they don't actually say
roger's name in the court documents
right but something makes me think when
you look at brian ulrich when he when he
was asked by the judge when in during
his guilty plea the judge asked him were
you planning with mr rhodes to make sure
that there was no peaceful transfer of
power by january 20th and he says yes
your honor uh brian allreds does the
lieutenant of stewart rhodes so
it really is it really is and then you
see we get confirmation in the media
that um joshua james another
lieutenant of stuart rhodes who is an
oath keeper who was protecting and next
to roger stone that day it all points
back
to to me
no points back to you
to roger stone to me i'm saying to me
when i'm breaking news
mastermind behind
that's why i know all this stuff folks
that's why i you're like right look if i
if i would do it hypothetically right
the way that i would do it would be
don't you don't you see that at some
point that these people are going to
start saying that type of [ __ ] like
they're going to get it hypothetically
the oj approach and they're like look
look
if i were to do it right right if i did
do it right
but we we see the heat coming down on
these folks because we have uh members
of congress now being um
summoned by their own um institution
by the january 6th election well i think
the well i think the most interesting
thing here and maybe you're going to
talk about this is the uh
dodge yes and their involvement now so
it's very interesting to see kind of the
approach is like okay
you know a lot of people you know we
were like dude we've said on the show
before give merrick garland a [ __ ]
beat
right like he's got a little
space to do he's dealing with and then
when he had the when he's like he's
dealing with a lot of people right
they've got 600 700 people that they've
already kind of uh charged with crimes
um there are other ones in addition that
they are actively pursuing they were big
time um
uh sorry i'm getting distracted by this
message
yeah okay
margie
yes
that's right
because you wouldn't say marjorie
margarita it's margaret but then i got
people in the chat over here saying no
no no that's all you said and then we
said margie back and they're like yes
that's what it is
all right
apologies for the confusion anyway back
to what i was saying people were railing
on us
railing on us and people said no no and
other people who were just like very
impatient for what mayor carlin was
still in patience still patient they're
like today would be a good day if
merrick garland would do his job it's
like dude what are you talking about the
guy's doing his job he is indicting they
are charging they were investigating
what we said from the beginning you
don't want to rush something like this
because if you [ __ ] it up and you ruin
it then what happens
what happens is it gets thrown out and
no one's able to actually investigate
this anymore because they screwed it up
the first time you want to make sure
that you measure 12 times and cut once
then measure once and have to cut 12
times right like you wanna it's very
calculated and so now you look at
january 6 and you look at doj and doj is
like hey you guys did a great job with
this committee you got them to admit
stuff
to you
that is now
actually uh usable that they may not
have used against us they might have
pled the fifth against us but with you
guys they just openly talked about it
well and there's another thing too that
i think a lot of people are forgetting
there's something called a federal
proffer and we've seen this in the joe
greenberg case um if you go look at some
of the reports in the joe greenberg case
there's federal proffers so what a
federal proffer is is it's it's not
really um an omission but you're
admitting facts but that doesn't mean
they can't go back and check those facts
right right um so you're not you're not
giving quite criminal liability um
to a degree maybe we should have um kfa
or popock on to explain the proffers and
why they would want these uh select
committee um testimony the the actual
written
uh transcripts of the testimony and i
bet my bet is gabe is that almost all
these people who are willing to go in
and talk to the january 6th select
committee were are willing to sit with
doj and probably have um
well potentially i don't know if anyone
who went directly to the doj would
actually openly admit to this stuff but
now that they have it on record they're
like so you said this and like [ __ ]
right you know and then well but it may
be interesting maybe though too if you
think about this if it is one if the
same person is talking to the goj and
the select committee the doj would have
interest in making sure that they are
saying the same things that they should
dislike
there may be you know whether it would
be actually publicly available in terms
of this person came in to give um you
know answer questions or give testimony
to this case i don't know if that would
have been revealed so there could be
people that the january 6 committee
actually spoke to that doj hasn't and it
might be for that reason that they
waited to be like
well before we start calling them both
in because that's what they asked they
were like can you give us over the
transcripts and they're like we can have
you come in right so benny thompson
benny thompson isn't just going to hand
over copies of the transcript it's just
yeah the same way that a director like
christopher nolan let's say who doesn't
want secrets to be leaked about a a
movie will have the actors come in into
a white room essentially which is a room
that has uh no recording devices
exactly yeah and they'll sit down at a
desk and there will be only one
physically printed copy of the script
and they have to read through it and
they've got you know a few hours to do
it and then they get up and they leave
and they don't have their phone on them
they don't have anything that they can
record with they were the only way that
they could read it was to come in and so
that's what benny thompson is is here
which which is typical with the doj like
even during a discovery during a case a
lot of times the lawyers don't just get
copies of stuff they just get access to
the information in a skiff type
environment right exactly like in a very
very sensitive case where they're trying
not to let information leak out like
you're saying these attorneys the
prosecutors and the defense would have
the chance to get into a room to look at
these things so this is not abnormal um
it seems abnormal to us because it's
like why wouldn't benny thompson just
put it on a goddamn trolley and take it
over there and say here here's all the
evidence well that's not exactly how in
the in the world of
prosecutions and indictments that you
that there would be because it has to
hold up to the scrutiny of an indictment
inside of a courtroom when a judge is
scrutinizing it to say yes these are
legitimate charges and a jury as well so
you don't want it tainted so if benny
benny thompson doesn't want his
testimony that he has that may include
some crimes that doj is investigating he
doesn't want that evidence tainted right
um in the transfer right
from one to the other so i i hope i hope
that this is a signal to folks out there
that yes this is taking a long time but
what is going to happen if donald trump
or some of his uh higher el echelon um
allies
are indicted is that doj and the
american people need to have a solid
locked case because he is going to
absolutely open the chaos machine here
yeah um and that will that will and he
will unleash it on us it is going to be
uh brutal uh we we will never see
anything like it if that is the case so
but
that's the same and again same reason
why we said
just give merrick garland a b he may not
be you know just because he didn't go
off after them immediately and was
charging this person charging that
person like you got to make sure
that you have everything lined up you
got your eyes down your t's crossed your
ducks in a row whatever way you want to
describe it right you want to make sure
that your case is button tight
so that when you go forward and actually
say i'm bringing you to court on these
charges you better be
[ __ ]
positive right that everything you've
got is right and here's the thing if if
the assumptions are correct in in the
media and sort of these uh these dot dot
these this dot to dot that we're putting
together here where you see
um people like marjorie taylor green uh
and others were saying martial law
martial law calling for martial law
we've seen a
genie as hints of it with genie thomas
text messages to mark meadows who is the
chief of staff if there really was this
call for martial law and stuart rhodes
was waiting for an order right was
waiting for an order from somewhere else
um and there's these stewart rhodes
lieutenants who are standing next to
what could be a person who has direct
contact with the cheeto dust mobster
himself
possibly a guy named roger stone that is
what it could seem like right if that is
the case folks they are so [ __ ] close
to making a case against roger stone and
donald trump
if you look at it if you look at it
objectively they are so close to making
a case against roger stone and possibly
donald trump if that is the case if
those are the dots that are connected if
that is what happened
now all's we're going off of is the
public information is what i'm looking
at and going hey this is a this is a
pretty direct line where you have one of
stewart rhodes lieutenants standing next
to roger stone roger stone is a really
good friend i mean in direct
communication not through mark meadows
but direct communication with the cheeto
dust mobster grandpa poopypants donald
trump himself while he's sitting there
basking in the glory of all these people
tearing down the capital and [ __ ] on
the constitution
if that is the case
folks the doj is damn close i mean
they're breaking down the door
of who is communicating with stuart
rhodes with that qrf which was the stash
of weapons across the potomac and and in
this interview
we talk about this with dakota and kind
of stewart's mindset because dakota
knows stewart mine said he i mean he was
his he was his father he taught him all
this stuff about militias um and and
dakota is super smart knows a lot about
this um so let's give it a listen
everyone stick around right after a
break when we come back
we will have dakota adams in an
interview and now again we recorded this
over the weekend so some of this new
news did not make it into this interview
so we'll have to have him back on in the
next few weeks to talk about those but i
do want to tell you stick around after
the interview because we have some video
and we are going to try to go
flashpoint we are going to go
super fast through the tweety tweets and
trendy trends
so stick around after the interview we
will we will surf the tweety tweets and
trendy trends with the [ __ ] list roundup
after the interview stick around dakota
adams up right after this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime please donate now
because those trump supporters you just
saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show thank you for
joining us we have one of our favorite
guests here dakota von adams the
estranged son of stuart rhodes um the
founder of the oath keepers uh dakota
thank you for joining us again for some
of the updates that are in the news
oh thank you for having me on and in my
bit of shameless self-promotion and
family promotion i am dakota v adams on
twitter
and
my mother is tasha adams which you
should also follow for
the latest closest possible inside view
of the mind of stuart rhodes as we go
into the coming year
of oath keepers and stewart being
completely [ __ ]
why i'm glad to have you and i'm glad
you plugged that is there a website that
the folks can go to uh before we start
asking questions uh that way they know
where to go not just to twitter but to a
website betgaltasha.com at her personal
blog is where you can go for updates on
my mom's book in progress
and her perspective on the oath keepers
related happenings that we're going to
see more and more of as the year
progresses and all of the secret santa's
workshop hours that the department of
justice and the january 6 committee have
been putting in
start to show up at our chimneys like
the prettiest best wrapped gifts you've
ever gotten right that's a perfect
christmas gift yeah i'm excited for that
santa claus to show up so let's get to
the questions let me ask the first
question here it seems like his paranoia
from the bundy ranch
has like
it's like you know that paranoia where
he was able to do a 180 flip on his
original mission of the oath keepers has
totally
done a 180 on like his whole reason of
to avoid prosecution for whatever
happened at the bundy ranch
yeah so
it's very interesting to
excuse me sorry it's very interesting to
think about it in terms of
like how bundy ranch kind of signaled
the point where stewart's self-interest
doomed the ideology behind oath keepers
because he
went missing in action for a long time
where people at bundy ranch had no idea
where the hell he was
and
a bunch of money was unaccounted for and
i and there's no there's no telling what
happened to it the
oath keeper's money situation was
intentionally too complicated for any
one person to keep a handle on so most
likely what do you mean by design
steward
by design stewart did that that's why
you have uh 50 separate active bank
accounts that are supposedly going to be
tied to state chapters and then never
used
is to create
an intentionally complicated money
situation
is that why he opened state chapters you
think is to create this this layering of
of organization so it's kind of like
buffering away from him or something oh
that's how the infrastructure was used
later but uh the state chapters happened
because people were independently
organizing their own state chapters
and then like oath keepers national was
finding out about them through events oh
so so so they were doing it without like
stewart's and the oath keepers the
national keepers permission and then is
that how he kind of brought him
underneath yeah and then they started
bringing them all into an official
structure and then the state chapters uh
became where he would recruit
leadership for
the board of directors and national
positions like vice president chaplin
editor
uh people in charge of different
projects all of those and then they
would have to deal with stewart have to
deal with a project that required
stewart to do any work become incredibly
burnt out and then leave and then
eventually the state chapter people
started getting burnt out independently
because
uh dues sharing like the membership dues
money that was supposed to be shared
part way with the state chapters for
state level organizing
and events and expenses never happened
and the lack of communication with oath
keepers national and lack of backup
or lack of support for any state level
things unless stewart could grandstand
there and happen to be in position to do
so
uh that started to wear on everyone or i
believe there are still
a lot of oath keepers groups that split
off from oath keepers national that are
continuing and going strong as
independent regional and and like state
level or local organizations
that are no longer affiliated with oath
keepers but started that way
but
the genesis of all that going wrong was
in bondi ranch where
uh stewart discovered a shortcut for
making a ton of money getting adolation
getting attention from people that had
more impressive military credentials
even come than he did even combat
experience
and higher education which was uh
pulling oath keepers operations like
the narcissistic supply
and to money
and being a cool guy
like in a leadership position that he
showered himself with
during bundy ranch became incredibly
addictive and it was
the exact same psychology that you see
in like the guys who showed up to the
maoki were standoff
to treat it like a get away from their
lives it was so much more fun
than the humdrum day-to-day of doing
nothing while you avoid the work of
running a national level veterans
organization so you think it's kind of
like a cosplay thing is that what you're
gonna see basically yes you get he got
to cosplay effectively as a general
right and right
this penis
fantasy were like the the tunnels that
we talked about before in the getaway
car and some of these other oh that was
all his personal paranoia that was
pre-exi that was pre-existing
i didn't know if it was all part of this
i didn't know this that was all part of
this cosplay this fantasy of that the
world would end and you know you would
have this where he would be the the
leader of the you know whatever
that actually
you actually you are right now that
you've now that i've let you phrase it
fully instead of interrupting you it's
uh that fan the persecution element of
his grandiose savior fantasy right is
what led to
the escape tunnels and the paranoia
about felony stops so you got so when
you travel in a convoy and anybody doing
any kind of oath keepers thing always
had to travel in a convoy because it was
a way for him to be in charge of a thing
you had to space out enough that the
cops could only stop one or two vehicles
at a time and at a felony stop
checkpoint
and
all that [ __ ] but
it kind of
i can't remember the correct
pronunciation when a tumor begins to
grow out of control
metastasized yes that is where it began
to get bad was bundy ranch and he went
through his deep dark depressive hole
from people making fun of him for
pulling out keepers out
to the perimeter and fleeing the ranch
when the rumors started to circulate
about a drone strike being authorized by
the department of defense which is
completely [ __ ] ridiculous
yeah
right that's what it's like
you only get away with something like a
move bombing once you're not going to
pull off an airstrike on a bunch of
white dudes in the desert and get away
with it in the national eye well you
know we see this layering that you're
talking about
like this this paranoia and this
layering in in the january 6 story in
recent articles um we we know there's an
article by politico i believe last month
and it talked about text messages and
the trova text messages that are
basically revealed um from stewart
rhodes and other oath keepers to trump
associates like mike flynn and roger
stone and even even a congressman uh
ronnie jackson i believe and there was
some more new reporting too um also
about you know some of the orders that
were supposed to be handed down
what do you do you think that's all for
part of his
uh abandoning abandonment of having him
his own self not involved in some of
this layering where he's kind of at the
central point of it or i mean how do you
feel about that what that looks like to
me is what i thought
a while ago is that
stuart
would revel in the attention i think
of being in the inner circle and close
to trump you want to position himself
basically as far from
personal harm as possible
within
his overriding fantasy of being a savior
george washington figure
and starting from at the beginning of
the trump administration
the game plan was basically to take oath
keepers in a trump critical like
constitutional watchdog direction
where it was going to be the
kind of an iteration on the same game
plan for ifr romney had won instead of
obama in 2008 where it might be less
energizing than a threatening democrat
winning but this guy still needs to be
watched because uh
any product of the political machine is
inherently untrustworthy and the
president
should have his [ __ ] called out all the
time well you know that's interesting
that you say that because in the
previous uh times that we've talked
you've said that there was two different
directions that uh when stewart really
concocted the oath keepers he had two
different plans one if romney or excuse
me one if mccain won
one if uh obama won and then you're
saying the romney election there's
there's another plan and then during the
trump election there seems to be another
plan so he's always he's always trying
to plan in scheme based on what the
national mood is exactly he is doing
exactly what he's always criticized
politicians are doing which is testing
the wind to see what's to see which way
the wind is blowing now he's basically
like a fair weather patriot it's kind of
yeah
and good good phrase the uh if the
original plan had been stuck to
then he would have kept to the same line
of thought and then criticize the trump
administration
whenever it did anything
unconstitutional which would have turned
into a huge moment for oath keepers to
step into the spotlight as a bipartisan
check against totalitarianism like it
was supposed to be in the original
mission statement
if they'd kept their eyes on the prize
and not
drifted right into crazy town by the
time of
uh disguised federal task forces
abducting people off the streets during
the black lives matter protests and it
could have been like wow this is exactly
what we've been warning about hey
conservatives
the police i mean just like right now
with the all the proposed uh proposed
checkpoints to require uh negative
pregnancy tests of women before they
cross state lines under some of these
new state laws
that is a back door into implementing
the police state in a way where
gun owning militia militia adjacent
conservatives will go along with it
until it's too late is how i would
phrase it right and that is exactly what
health keepers could have done but
stewart's self-interest in his fear of
being arrested by
a democrat administration over bundy
ranch caused him to cling increasingly
to the coattails the trump
administration
the proud boys going to the berkeley
protests brought in more money even if
he got mad that gavin mcguinness and the
proud boys kept getting top going at
events and he didn't
and then
like i think
tasha has it right mom has it right
where she thinks that he got hooked up
with somebody when he was supposedly
pulling security at the maga ball after
trump's inauguration
and then as he became more and more
paranoid over what would happen to him
if a democrat ever took office again
there's this guy
there's this guy who's telling him they
can make everything okay if he can bring
his people on board
now in the past uh stewart had been
approached to be the paramilitary arm
of weird [ __ ]
and then turned it down because being
independent was more in his
self-interest at the time the last one
was a person i believe to be matt shea
because i know he was associated with
matt shea a bunch after that point and
went and spoke at the uh
marblehead community
and everything that matt shea is heavily
involved with this is the state
representative who had the internal
dossier in his office calling for
uh a biblical war against communism in a
christian takeover in the united states
sounds like a really interesting fellow
by the way yes he's also just recently
been uh
in trouble for trying to
get uh ukrainian children and uh
separated from their parents and orphans
uh shipped the united states from
refugee camps in poland without any
paperwork whatsoever and didn't want to
give his name to polish authorities
so matt shea is i probably to be adopted
out into proper christian households and
raised as stormtroopers like he is
in that side of it but somebody
in an evangelical christian group that
was somewhat underground approach
stewart
asking if oath keepers would serve as
part of their paramilitary arm if a
collapse came for creating
an american christian theocracy
that would take over in the absence of
the government and stewart turned him
down
but i think that was matt shea and he
kept contact with that matt shea after
that point even though it's basically
the same thing matt shape believes in
even if it wasn't the same guy
so that tells me that he was keeping his
options open in the background so even
if he started out being critical of
trump
on the constitution
he was going to keep that back channel
open
in case he needed a plan b
and then as he gets more and more afraid
of what happens if trump loses the
election
and there is
a liberal president
over the department of justice
what's going to happen to him and that's
where he starts to get sucked into
trump's circle and i do not believe that
he would have gone as far
as to be
the aggressor operating in a hostile
space like dc where in the past he's
been incredibly critical of
i can't remember the dude's name uh
i want to say fishbach but that's
completely wrong that's something
something people were talking him like
in a
calling him in a derogatory fashion he
was a
right-wing libertarian dude who was
leading
going to lead a second amendment rights
march on washington dc years in the past
and we're trying to find that got
shouted down
so what what what was what was stewart's
mindset about washington dc exactly then
like what would he i mean i mean what
was his opinion on you know going into
dc and you know
like you said what was his objection to
it uh that it was a terrible idea that
would
start a civil conflict between the
right-wing militia movement and the
federal government in a position where
the militia movement would almost
certainly lose and look like the
aggressor thereby
immediately taking a defeat and losing a
huge chunk of popular support in one
fell swoop he thought it was the dumbest
thing he'd ever heard in his life
to take guns into washington dc
as some kind of political movement well
you know he thought that malheur was the
stupidest thing he'd ever heard of too
and then
he goes and does this
he goes and
plots out the qrf and stashes weapons
across the potomac with guys apparently
waiting to uh take the qr the armed qrf
across with the boat if necessary which
leads me to believe
that he had assurances
that he would not face consequence for
it right right and assurances from
someone who i don't know may
may be able to do something i don't know
maybe the word pardon comes to mind i
don't know
but that's the other thing i wonder too
is like you know whether or not there
was actually actually direct
communication from trump to say roger
stone to
stewart you know i wonder if if roger
was like yeah yeah yeah yeah like i'll
i'll do i'll figure it out and then
stewart like on just the trust of his
word was like great okay cool we'll shut
that [ __ ] up and we'll be ready to go
whenever you need us but there was
actually no like security
of
a pardon well i think there were
there are some people claim surfacing
that roger stone was auctioning off
pardons for tens of thousands of dollars
a piece and then was unable to follow
through with the prominent promise of
the auction pardons
there is the uh
witness testimony from
the man whose name i can't recall even
though i should who just pled guilty
stating that stewart called an
intermediary who refused to put him on
directly with donald trump you're not
talking about joshua you're not talking
about joshua james right you're talking
about the the newest oath keeper the
newest yeah the guy who says he was in a
hotel room when stuart tried to
personally reach trump over the phone
and got told no by the intermediary that
he would not be handing him off to speak
to trump personally for this phone
conversation
and basically left a message begging to
be called up to fight at 6 00 p.m that
day
when it when january 6 was winding down
it was clear that they had not won there
was the connection between and this is a
side thing joel greenberg joel greenberg
matt gates and roger stone
around pardons as well
right um but that obviously never never
you know bubbled up to something on the
surface it was just like
there i don't know if it was from joel
greenberg's camp or someone else but the
idea of auction off pardons was
something that was at least floated
within that camp
so yes to your point of what you're
saying like yeah obviously that is
totally on brand and then there's but
there is that element where i'm like is
roger stone just pocketing the money for
whoever the highest bidder is without
any sort of reassurances from trump or
even if he was like oh i'm i even spoke
to trump he was like i'll take your
money
and then i'm just gonna
hit the road you know i don't know if
you're asking
that question yeah i'm not i'm just
gonna say i don't know if you're asking
dakota that question but i'll answer the
question hell to the yeah yeah that's
that's that's on brand for roger stone
now we don't i guess we'll find out
maybe eventually in federal court i
think i think the uh the person that
you're speaking of who has pled uh
guilty uh in in the uh conspiracy here
is brian ulrich uh yes that is the third
guilty plea in the oak keeper's specific
conspiracy so far
he doesn't claim i don't in the
documents that i saw doesn't say that he
knows the identity of the intermediary
but that stuart called the intermediary
and asked to directly speak the trump
was denied
left a message begging to begging for
oath keepers and other militia groups to
be called up to fight um and this was
well after it was clear that
the coup had not gone off as planned
right because we talked about this
before because your assumption is
because because of where and how they
had the qrf stashed that and what the
mission looked like it appeared to be on
the ground and how they were acting like
their movements it really did and and
the fact that they were waiting for what
maybe martial law to be declared um it
really looked like they were trying to
find or create some sort of chaos i
think that's the word you used in the
last time we spoke yeah some sort of
chaos that way they could they could
send up the order of martial law it
could be sent back down and then they
could
do the thing that they had planned to do
which was to
basically
[ __ ] on our constitution and and take it
to authoritarian rule at that point i
mean yeah keep trump in power right um
possibly arrest members of congress as
it becomes clear
that there probably was a plan to
just
abduct pence into the back of a trump
loyalist secret service vehicle and keep
him away from the capital
while the election
was
ruled decertified
right and then that didn't go off
because pence became incredibly canny at
the last moment and refused to bend on
the advice of dan quayle
so then the second chance the second
option is to
create
a giant street ball brawl riot with the
expected antifa counter protesters and
blm counter protesters everyone thought
was going to be there didn't show up
create a riot pitting trump supporters
against the capitol police and in
the chaos of that try to secure
members of congress as prisoners
right that way that way the ones that
avoid the ones that would vote to to not
sir are to to to not certify the
election that would be the majority at
that point let me read you a quote um
from this npr article
from the court hearing where brian
ulrich actually pled guilty this is the
question that the judge asked in the
hearing uh the judge says did you do
that sir agree with mr rhodes and
develop a plan to stop the lawful
transfer of presidential power
by january 20th 2021. that was the
question
ulrich's reply was yes
your honor um so an open court is um
admitting that they were developing a
plan now
we're we're using we're using the
evidence that we have at hand to know
what the plan is i mean eventually um if
stuart were to go to trial this plan
will be laid out in front of us and the
evidence and the discovery will be
incredibly excited that the uh it looks
like the january 6th congressional
committee and the department of justice
have been working together this entire
time
what what gives you what gives you that
sense what gives you that sense it's
that was the recent article that came
out i believe it was uh regarding uh
subpoenas for records and subpoenas for
testimony
for the five members of congress
right that they're trying to call up to
be questioned and it was revealed that
this is part of a series of subpoenas
i cannot remember the detail
from the article i've had a lot on my
mind it's been like stuff information
has just been falling
in one eye and out the other along with
uh
all kinds of statistical math that i
never remember again but it was that
they
also had department of justice people
right that were involved with the
interview process that had been filing
their own series of subpoenas
for
something that overlapped with
what they were specifically doing at the
time with subpoenaing these members of
congress
but was not
completely the same thing so that
implies
another overlapping investigation run by
the department of justice with
information sharing well you know those
five congressmen uh me and gabe talked
about them on the show the other day
they're kevin mccarthy uh jim jordan uh
andy biggs mo brooks and then what's
what's the last one what's the guy from
pennsylvania what's up scott perry yeah
scott perry that's [ __ ] bucks um he's
he's another one that is in the subpoena
but um we've actually had um karen
agnipolo and michael popock on from
legal af and karen i think has
specifically told me and gabe
because a lot of people think that the
january 6 select committee has to give a
referral for crimes
and they don't like the department of
justice doesn't need the select
committee to give them a referral like
they can be running these investigations
and finding the same evidence at the
same time and the january 6 select
committee can actually be giving the
evidence to the department of justice
like it doesn't have to be this official
thing which we see with the contempt
charge
where they're trying to hold them in
contempt of congress which is an
official uh congressional thing that
they have to do
to do a referral because they have to
state hey you're in contempt now we're
referring it to the department of
justice right so this because the crimes
that are committed on january 6 are
outside of the january 6th select
committee and their contempt uh
jurisdiction so
people are kind of getting those things
like meshed up in a ball and i think
yeah that's what they're seeing and what
they're assuming is that the department
of justice will do nothing and they're
assuming that the committee is a big
congressional show that will
result in a strongly worded memo and i
don't think that's what's happening at
all well you know we're we're actually
me and gabe are going to stream the uh
the public hearings and we're going to
try to leave live stream them from front
to back um to try to give some
commentary and let the public see it
as best we can um and hopefully a lot of
people tune in to watch that not just
for our sake but to actually see what
the story is for january 6th because i
think that's the confusing part about
the story of january 6. and and that it
always seems to go back to this one
focal point other than trump but the one
focal point that it always points back
to
is stuart rhodes like every single time
like enrique tario last time we talked
uh
the the proud boys leader at the time he
was uh he was hauled out of his house he
was indicted uh we we know we talked
about him and stuart meeting the day
before january 5th in a parking garage
um we talked about the proud boys and
how oath keepers and proud boys never
get along and then you find out then we
find out here in the last couple weeks
that joshua james and this alright were
all in communication and all with roger
stone who is supposed to have security
from the problems because a political
party was switched at the last second
right kelly makes kelly makes um one of
the oath keepers from florida kelly
makes actually discusses plans to
provide security for figures like roger
stones alex jones uh ali alexander mike
flynn and some of these people actually
didn't take the security but roger stone
did because we see evidence of joshua
james
right next to roger stone um during the
january 6th the happenings of january 6.
so
this is very aortic direction right
right it's very it's very very uh
telling that all this stuff kind of
leads back to
to stuart like he's kind of this central
focal point and there's always it always
sticks out in my mind dakota when we
talk to you and i talked about this
during marjorie taylor green hearings
because she was asked did you ever
advocate for martial law not the store
marshals but like the
like martial arts like martial law how
it's actually spelled but she was asked
about martial law and i actually went on
a tangent during those hearings during a
break
where i always come back to what you say
about the qrf and why it was there like
why
why in the world would you need a stash
of weapons in a spot where you would
need it at hand at a quick notice
if an order would come down for anything
anything other than martial law like
what else is there reason
to have that across there if they were
just there to have aid to make sure
security to protect whoever like why
would you need a stash of weapons
across the potomac why and it always
sticks out in my mind like that only if
they were going to be forgiven after the
fact or death
or effectively deputized is a way to
freeze
up officially beforehand as trump's
personal paramilitary and i think why we
keep seeing stewart crop up and also why
my family didn't hear from him for
months on end is he no longer needed the
narcissistic supply
of
being in contact with his family to even
play at
being a dad because he was
soaking
in the supply of being in the middle of
this historic event
associated with donald trump and his
inner circle
and the reason why you see him
all over the place so often in all of
these events and all these people
talking about it
or
very pointedly not talking about it in
the case of mtg
who
can't remember anyone she has ever
talked to any place she's ever been
or what day it was over the course of
her entire life according to her
testimony on the stand
it's because stewart has
not only acted out of fear
and short-term personal gain in the
donations that being pro-trump could
give a flagging organization
but has seen an opportunity to insert
himself
as trump's go-to guy for paramilitary
action his general in other words like
this general fantasy maybe like
his uh act his uh honorary general or
chief of
real american internal security
incorporated or whatever the [ __ ] it was
going to be where it was going to be his
personal
brown shirt
essay division
for whatever he needed
because the proud boys
are street brawlers oath keepers if you
want a right-wing militia to back you up
in the middle of a gun fight
i would have called the real guys in
oath keepers before i would have called
the proud boys proud boys have their
place in their niche role
stuart commanding oath keepers
could have functioned excellently for
whatever role they needed
an armed paramilitary to fulfill
without using federal police or the
military
and that is the position i think stewart
was intentionally trying to weasel his
way into
for trying to get the highest position
he could in the post coup
donald trump forever world well so so
the maga king thing is real
i think so i think that was in trump's
mind the whole time trump yeah all
positions of authority as basically
futile he thinks that
being the president everyone should have
ride or die personal loyalty to him
because he's a narcissistic sociopath
and he uh
like once he got adjusted having
presidential power
it's inconceivable of him to let it go
right right i mean january 6 was i mean
like obviously you we have we have seen
signs of this throughout the presidency
but january 6 when you're sitting in
in your oval office for three to four
hours not doing anything
you know in terms of actually stopping
it you know then you see a video where
he's like
i love you all
because in his mind he's like i i truly
love you all you are now literally
storming this building because you want
to keep me as president because you're
part of delusional yeah he thought they
looked too trashy he would have liked uh
better dressed yuppier rioters
scary boat shoes and some you know
button-up shirts maybe you know he
wanted he wanted all the dudes
who almost get murdered over business
cards from american psycho oh he just
wanted a bunch of heroes really he
wanted all of patrick bates co-workers
to show up in a riot for him because it
would have looked higher class on tv
oh yeah you i mean a high-class coup is
something that yeah it's an
authoritarian desires well i mean a
high-class coup has a different
different taste in your mouth than just
like a regular old coup you know he's
like yeah well the last time the last
time we had one of those they uh all
almost got they all almost got killed by
spendley butler it happens that way so
there's two there's two parts of this
story that haven't happened yet though
that i want to now then i want to get
your take on and you alluded to one
earlier but there's two things number
one
uh you you mention the fact that uh
stuart was terrified to go to dc that
the militia thought it was really stupid
to take
especially an armed second amendment
protest
or an armed force into dc because
it would be seen as an aggressive act if
you start a fight with the police you
lose
especially if they
corner you in on the bridge
that
the fish guy whose name i can't quite
recall was planning to march across
so you're going to lose you're going to
look like the aggressor you're going to
lose public opinion at the beginning of
a civil conflict that you just
instigated you thought it was moronic
and not not only that you're saying that
he thought that it could be the end of
kind of right-wing militias in the
country in the movement so do you think
do you think the prosecution if and
that's my other question is do you think
stewart rhodes takes this to the bank if
he goes all the way to the end here he
goes through the entire trial does he
plead guilty that's my next question but
the first off do you really do do you
think that this the insurrection the
violent insurrection where they're
trying to overthrow the constitution to
make donald trump the manga king do you
think
that
um is going to absolutely permanently
damage not just the oath keepers but all
the militia groups out there because you
are raised in this culture and you know
these you know these people you know
them front back sideways and you know
how they act you know uh these
organizations uh interact with culture
so tell us do you think that this is
going to damage them permanently or
absolutely i think so i think there are
a ton of people who would absolutely not
be down with a right-wing dictatorship
and
what stewart was basically going to
accept in the bargain for saving his own
skin and weaseling his way into a
favored position with dictator trump is
they don't really
most of these guys
specifically i won't say most of these
guys
what you would get continuing to support
that are the people who are willing to
support
a right-wing take over a right-wing like
to tarleton
can't talk totalitarian takeover in
general
are the hangers on
and the bottom of the barrel scrapings
the people that would be the most
dangerous opponents in a civil war i
don't believe are down
for
king trump being ruler of the united
states with the constitution suspended
right
especially now
that the catastrophic [ __ ] up
of
leaking the supreme the current supreme
court pending decision
drawing if this was an attempt to
distract everyone from the january six
uh
hearings and the trials that are
upcoming it was badly mistimed it's like
i said on twitter it's like a magician's
flourish with [ __ ] up timing that just
draws the eye to the switch of the cards
instead of distracting from it right or
like the smoke bomb and then you see
them leave the stage
yeah just badly missed you mean like the
smoke doesn't dissipate enough and it's
just like a little puff of smoke yeah
walk off
or you're just jumped the gun and you
walked out ahead of the column of smoke
that was going to conceal your path to
the concealed back door
it's a horribly mis-timed
attempt to distract and now that
everyone is paying attention
it's going to completely wreck the
credibility
of the right-wing militia movement of
oath keepers of trumpism of all of it
with everyone who doesn't want
a
maybe theocratic
christian or maybe just right-wing in
general
uh dictatorship
with a strong man who is promising to
fix everything and that means you're
going to get
not to say that the remaining crowd
isn't incredibly dangerous the remaining
crowd who doesn't want that there's a
lot of them they are incredibly
dangerous
but the people who would be
the most dangerous
are going to bleed out of the movement
and the gop
if
they continue on this path in fact i
think they lost a lot of people i think
the gop was already i think the
republicans were already on the road to
losing
a ton more voters than they expected in
the coming midterms
and getting hurt badly by their
continued association with trump
and now they've doubled down on it
i think i think yeah i think there's
there's there's a few things that you
brought up over the last few minutes
that i think are really interesting one
whoever leaked it maybe jenny thomas
don't know and it turns
and uh he's not saying he's not saying
but i'm not seeing it
i'm just like if there was someone that
had some sort of uh
reason to leak to distract to this yeah
roe v wade would be like hey listen i
was involved let's forget about january
6th obviously like you said the time
slowly off whoever that might be maybe
gina thomas maybe not
uh i think that is a very interesting
point and i think that you know with the
upcoming january uh sixth uh hearings on
june 9th and for the next eight eight
days or so whatever throughout the the
month of june i think it's only just
ramping those efforts up because we're
looking
at a total breakdown of this country
right to say like
you know these people want a complete
control over women's bodies they want
complete control over uh the government
or decisions when it doesn't go their
way
like people are beginning to actually
see like oh there's there's actually
this crazy ass plan that they have
whether well construct or not
but then you have the people you brought
up which are like the ones who are
the most dangerous are the ones who are
going to deflect right and the way that
i see it in my mind are they look at
this whole situation as a means to an
end and i agree with you i completely
agree that those people are the most
dangerous because they have ulterior
motives in mind and the third thing i
think is that most hilarious of course
with the republican party is just the
complete hypocrisy and projection which
is i don't want a police state i don't
want a tyrannical government i don't
want anyone who's totalitarian and then
of course on the flip side they're like
i want to control your body i want to
overturn the election and i want to say
whatever you say is the wrong thing and
i'm always right so i want to control or
eliminate public education i want to
get rid of gay marriage interracial
marriage ban condoms ban contraceptives
that are not for married couples right i
want checkpoints for women starting with
women crossing state lines
i want the laws of my state to apply in
other states that is a
really nice
callback to the
uh fugitive slave acts that was one of
the main causes of the civil war is
there is definitely
and it's also shown that the republican
party has been completely hijacked
by
this relative minority in the country
who desperately want these things and
just by agitating non-stop
and trying to work their way into
positions of power they now
control
the agenda of the entire gop
and the old guard have to go along with
it to preserve their positions and
preserve their careers and it's actually
a really neat looking
road map
for a hostile takeover of the democratic
party for anyone who is sick
of the traditional old guard democratic
party acting like a helpless minority no
matter what the actual situation is it's
just if you organize with your friends
and you don't stop trying to seize power
over the course of years and keep
showing up to all of the elections that
aren't big and glamorous and shiny
you can seize control
don't don't say that out loud what are
you doing you're giving away the game no
i'm let me let me tell you because you
you two have made some great points and
i think i think it's worth considering
um some of the things that possibly with
this leak of the
supreme court um overturning roe v wade
number one it goes back to the
constitution because these people are
they absolutely love what is what is
well they love talking about it they
never love actually what it is or what
it stands for which again on this show
we say the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not liberty because
liberty is what we really strive for in
this country the rights and the freedoms
are just the thing that delivers you
the actual liberty and
i actually you know thinking about it
listening to you guys talk
if we look at the the
january 6 public hearings that are going
to happen throughout june we've heard
that there's going to be eight of them
it seems like that the supreme court
decision might have come down
during those hearings which maybe maybe
the right wing didn't want that to get
lost in their movement because a lot of
them at first were like yay we did it
and and they all of a sudden realized
that they had awakened this sleeping
giant right like they had realized oh
maybe this isn't such a great thing and
they're like leaking who leaked it right
like that was their first inclination
was to pat themselves on the back
and almost immediately they realized
that they had they had totally changed
the conversation to this
that actually the constitution is
something that is really important in
this country and what is happening is
the january 6 hearings the public
hearings are going to focus on
these people were trying to overturn the
document that protects your rights and
possibly the right to your bodily
autonomy like how important this is like
these people who are trying to
functionally take away your rights
through
functional government by
appointing supreme court justices that
seem to be bought and paid for to get to
win elections in congressional districts
and and the state legislators and these
governorships to erode away at your
constitutional rights wherever and
whenever they can
these are the people who wanted to
actually overthrow the constitution and
it violently seized power right suspend
constitutional protections
place the country under martial law
under their control
and it's also going to be enticing
because it's going to raise the prospect
of the people
responsible for packing the supreme
court with [ __ ] lunatics the way that
it is now
facing
consequences for there are many other
illegal actions
and a lot of people are going to be
paying attention that were not paying
attention previously and i think any
attempt to deflect
attention because now the narrative is
they're
trying to equate
the protesters outside of the justices
homes right right with the january 6
insurrection i'm hearing this repeated
by people who genuinely think
that uh january 6 was just a bunch of
old people wandering into the capitol
after the cops invited them in as i
don't see a bunch of protesters at the
supreme court justice house that are
smearing [ __ ] on their walls or spa
spraying their mace yeah breaking break
getting into shield while shoving
matches with riot cops and spraying like
this is not absolutely fake this is a
huge difference in comparison and the
only people that are going to buy into
that are so ideologically suckered in
right that they were going to be showing
up for the gop no matter what anyway you
know um no that's okay because you
brought up um protesting outside justice
zones but we seen you know the hilarity
of some of this is that susan collins
called the cops i want to show you a
video dakota maybe you can react to it
um this is apparently
and i don't know where gabe found this
video he must have found it somewhere on
the deep parkway found it on reddit
somewhere i'm sure that is the deep web
right
so so but i want to show you this video
it it is hilarious um because it seems
to show the police officers
that showed up when susan collins
called because there was this sinister
sidewalk chalk let's let's watch
detective i just got senator collins
about the sidewalk she's very concerned
he's working who detective johnson with
csi who called crime scene it's just
chalk on a sidewalk no
scene investigation well i'm glad i
arrived when i did thank you sorry is
this a joke no but i'll tell you what is
a joke whoever decided to dust my chalk
scene for prince i was following a
protocol and i bet you also thought it
was a smart idea downloading the
sidewalk note in chalk yeah so jesus you
might as well just piss all over my
evidence detective
you're going to want to see this coming
oh and uh while i'm gone try not to ruin
any more of my chalk scene
is this guy serious as serious as they
come it was assigned to the hopscotch
massacre of 2015. what he organized a
statewide manhunt for the sidewalk
chocolate worked on it 24 7. but then
the case went cold and now he blames
himself for not solving it even ruined
his marriage well i've never heard of
this case we're trying to make it look
funny that he's eating chocolate
are you saying that all the time
mountain dew code red [ __ ] he's back who
the sidewalk chalker oh my god it was
just a harmless chalk message supporting
women's reproductive rights you may
think it's harmless but politics
is where i draw the line
[Music]
shock scene investigation gabe i don't
know where the hell you found this video
i don't know i'm amazed that there are
people that use tick tock that are
old enough to remember csi miami that's
i'm one of them
so so i think it's hilarious but but to
your point though
that that this this authoritarian rule
it does get clownish right like they
clown so much that the establishment
even susan collins herself clowns
herself by trying to you know trip over
her clown shoes to try to seem like oh
you know to sycophant to these people
i'm the victim i was the right i'm here
they were trying to attack me and it's
like susan
somebody wrote chalk on the public
sidewalk right that kind of [ __ ] is why
it is
so important to show up for primary
elections right not just the protests
but the elections is not right it's the
protest right because if voting
was worthless
and this is something i see now that i'm
on twitter and i can be angry 24 7. uh
which is the real purpose of twitter
yeah that's what you love
right
and speech it's about being angry it's
about being angry it's about being angry
nonstop and new being angry in new ways
but right um i seen all these people
going oh we've what do you mean vote
harder we already voted like no you
[ __ ] turned out for one presidential
election right in a last-ditch effort to
plug the biggest hole at the bottom of
the sinking ship and it bought us a
little bit of time
right but
we're still pale in the water out of
this yeah we are still
on a semi-wrecked schooner in the middle
of a hurricane
everything's broken we're taking on
water the people that are supposed to be
helping us bail out bail it out
are
actively breaking the pumps
and stabbing the bottoms of their bodies
did we need that my bad you know right
like oh my goodness
i love it i love your description of it
dakota i love your description yeah half
the people on the titanic with you have
private life vests that they're pretty
sure will work and they all took out
insurance policies on the boat
right right so what is happening now is
the consequence of all these people that
are like well we did vote not
understanding that to get us to this
point
the republicans
like the hardcore
my party is my sports team tribe family
and religion
conservatives who would cheer for a
dictatorship those ones
have been showing up for every single
election right midterm
school board town council
state rep congressional
presidential
for 40 goddamn years right they are like
dog they elect fascist dog catchers
they're like that guy well i mean you
look at their group and they are you
know again just really good at
well [ __ ] messaging but they're
really good at nailing it home
to induce fear in yourself to be like
well i don't want to become a socialist
bankrupt nation like i want to be
american and i want to be freedom you
know free and all this stuff but at the
end of the day it's like that's as
democrats or as liberals or whoever you
are that on the left side of this on the
isle or spectrum
you know and you want a dictatorship at
this point yeah exactly anyone who does
that is a very good that is a very good
uh line in the sand to draw if you do
not want a dictatorship you know this is
where you stand if you do then obviously
you're the the pro putin pro
insurrection uh mega trump king [ __ ]
right but you look at the people who
always go to the polls who always vote
right there is that fear that there is
that emotion that is driving them to say
i don't want this thing that my local
councilman or senator or whoever is is
is repeating over and over that it's
going to become this this crazy uh
socialist state or whatever it is
biden's going to steal all your baby
formula exactly exactly that's another
example but we shouldn't get babies
formula by the way we should give them
yeah no once they're born no formula
it's always both sides of the fence with
these [ __ ] listen you can you
gotta pick a lane and they won't well
they try to drive between the lane and
then you're like you're dangerous and
you're causing damage to everyone around
you and that's what they're like no no
no it's free well it's if you never pick
a lane then you're always right in
retrospect as long as you're using an
edited and [ __ ] edited video
compilation that's right that's what
that's what trump has always done and
and it's it's an easy way to draw drive
wedges right yeah and that's what that's
what the because you guys described as
the left and and dakota said right if
you're just against a dictatorship
because we've seen a lot of people even
in the public sphere that have been
pro-life for a long time struggle with
this leak and struggle with this
decision for scotus because
they're pro-life and they don't want roe
v wade but they know what it means when
this decision happens that it was an
authoritarian type of rule that put this
on the people of the united states no
matter how much they're against abortion
or why or that the gop immediately sees
all right to 100
telegraph what they actually plan to do
which i think is the real mistake
is instead of letting it remain roe v
wade they immediately jumped on we're
going to get rid of interracial marriage
we're going to get rid of gay marriage
we're going to
reverse [ __ ] all the way back through
browning v board of education back to
the decisions about whether the united
states can force you to not teach your
children
your native language as a first language
they're going to roll it all back the
state governments are going to [ __ ]
ban condoms and contraceptives and start
instituting checkpoints that demand
medical tests of you
and they made it so obvious at the front
that repealing roe v wade or overturning
it is only the first step in their wider
program that people that are single
issue on roe v wade are being confronted
with this massive wall of consequences
behind it that they would not be if
their gop like the maga captured
fundamentalist gop
had exercised a little bit of patience
people might have let that slip under
the radar but they've become so
overconfident as a result of four years
of daddy trump that they can't do that
part of their brand that's part of their
brand is to always overstep to always
over negotiate to always over bid
you know um not to toot my own owner or
pat myself on the back but you brought
up banning condoms um i was one of the
first ones that said as this decision
came down like this is they're gonna
start you white dudes out there you
trumped up white dudes that go into a
gas station two years from now and you
want to get your condoms because you
want to get your [ __ ] on and and the the
store clerk's like we don't have condoms
anymore what are you doing they're like
what do you mean i'm kind of like
they're illegal like what the [ __ ] are
you talking these people don't
understand they really don't understand
what they're cheering on they have no
[ __ ] clue right they have no clue
what they're chewing on i also said that
elon musk won't ever own twitter and i
think i'm gonna be right uh so i don't
i'm gonna pat myself
if we let these idiots rule well no
condoms
must go also never on twitter uh the
last question the last point i want to
ask you about uh before we go
is stewart road taking this thing all
the way to the end zone i think he will
i think he will unless he gets a very
favorable plea deal and it looks like he
is dead certain to lose because he
remembers
um people from bundy ranch who skated it
when they went to trial
describe that describe that describe
that
because
it's because uh like for example eamon
bundy personally
did not go to prison until after malheur
and then he was let off from that
because there was so many federal
informants
inside his inner circle at malheur that
it created
maybe not reasonable that but reason to
doubt that there was you did this of his
own free will and cognition
or and created a shadow of a doubt that
it was entrapment
and
he saw that several times
people who did not take the plea bargain
had a shot so you're saying his
confidence comes from
those past experiences with these
paramilitia uh type convictions and
types escaping consequences when they
went to trial because of a specter
of federal informants and entrapment
which
is something unless and federal agencies
are going to have to learn
is that the [ __ ] that they do when
they're in trapping
uh muslim men into bomb plots that are
99 federal agent right will not work in
a court of law prosecuting a christian
white guy it's just a simple fact is the
precedent set
in
nabbing
muslim men that are vulnerable to
radicalization and
far left groups and environmental groups
and eco-terrorists like to what you're
saying like while we've been on this
call or while we've been on this chat
right now there was a mass shooting
where 10 people were killed by an
extremist manifesto leaked online like
while we've been talking this whole
thing is happening [ __ ] jesus christ and
but it is an example of you know a
christian white guy escorted in cuffs to
the to the police car nothing you know
no kind of thing did you buy him burger
king this time i mean or was it i think
they i think they got him a a happy meal
maybe they bought him i mean you know
what what was the one cop he said uh
about uh he was yeah he he was
disgruntled he was he was
much discouraged [ __ ] like come on give
me a [ __ ] break and the thing is is
this
this person also is a self-described
white supremacist and anti-semite and of
course
totally he went on his shooting spree
yes it was in a supermarket he went on
his shooting spree in buffalo new york
in a grocery store in a predominantly
black area so that he could kill black
people yeah and he
threw a bunch of he threw a bunch of dog
whistles into his manifesto which i
would not recommend you read because
it's kind of worthless
just to
the they were all things that he saw
from previous white supremacist
manifestos i think that he saw got media
attention
so i think he's kind of like like a
copycat copycat he's a copycat
he is
a gestalt copycat
of everyone under the sun who was a
white supremacist mass shooter including
dylan roof and just cribbed [ __ ] from
all their manifestos and jammed it
together it's bordering on a plagiarized
manifesto so he basically wants his name
he's a white supremacist he wants his
name out there as well yeah the sad
thing is that's what we do in this
country we may yeah we who are the the
uh perpetrators the the we signal boost
the perpetrators of mass shootings and
then we wonder why we have a problem
when was the last time there was a
school or a mall shooting in switzerland
or finland where there are
the only like two of the only places in
the world where there are as many
semi-automatic rifles floating around at
random as there are in the united states
it doesn't happen because we have a
cultural problem yeah right
i've said that before i've said and and
really um you know to your point there
and and i grew up in white america i
grew up in rural white america it is and
you know a lot of people might knock me
for this but it is a white culture
problem this is a white gun culture
problem where white males think that
they own everything they cannot be
punished i mean we see it inside media
even like like even joe rogan on his
show he's always talking about how i get
to get you got you used to get to would
do anything you wanted like that's not
freedom you don't get to do whatever you
want that's not [ __ ] true you've
never been able to just drive down the
road at 500 miles an hour you've never
been able to just speed through a stop
sign only if you weren't get caught you
can't just punch someone in the mouth
because you don't like them at the
grocery store like you can't do whatever
you want that is all [ __ ] just
because you think you have the
entitlement and the privilege to do
whatever you want doesn't actually mean
you do but maybe you're alluding to the
fact that maybe they do do
and um you're saying that stewart's
mindset of his trial may be that he does
have that privilege he does have the
right to do whatever he wants and it's
that white gun culture type mentality
this this entitlement entitlement the
history of gun control and
the massacre of fringe groups nobody
gave a [ __ ] about the move bombing
people who live i
about to make myself sound ignorant if
it's not philadelphia that was
philadelphia right i you know you got me
um it was a uh
fringe black group
that
took up residence inside an apartment
building and refused to leave and holed
up in there there was a standoff the
police ended the standoff by dropping
dynamite from a [ __ ] police
helicopter and burned down two city
blocks
nobody who people grew up in the city of
philadelphia and never know that it
happened yeah i don't i've never heard
of this either and the probably the
reason why is because of who they was
perpetrated against black people yes
exactly people the uh gun laws
the beginning of the trend in gun laws
that eventually led to uh
the atf and the fbi killing randy
weaver's family started with
reagan coming down on the black panthers
exactly right yep
don't don't bring those guns to the
building here in the country
the worst most egregious gun laws in the
whole country everyone loves to lay at
the feet of liberal democrats the reason
they are the way that they are
the reason why
they are structured in a way that is so
intentionally confusing
changeable and meant to create obviously
as many felons who cannot vote as
possible is because the original
template was to [ __ ] with black people
by the hand of ronald reagan so you have
these things
where
law enforcement people inside law
enforcement get away with a thing
they get away with the philadelphia
police get away with bombing an
apartment building and burning down to
city blocks and killing a bunch of
people
they get away with
gun confiscation to [ __ ] up the black
panther movement they get away with that
[ __ ]
and then somebody inside the feds tries
to use this against
white extremists and it all goes to hell
and creates an enormous cultural
firestorm it's because i think
federal law enforcement forgets about
white privilege because they have a
blind spot for institutional privilege
because in all honesty
i'd say
federal police agencies are in no way
immune to being affected by it so they
don't want to acknowledge that it's real
so they fall prey to it even in trying
to prosecute cases and that's where you
get people
walking away
after the malheur standoff because of a
level of informant involvement that
would not have even been considered
noteworthy if they were muslim
extremists and carried out the exact
same actions
and that
so in a way
these stuff this effect of
white militia dudes getting away with
[ __ ] that they should not have been able
to given the precedent of what charges
stick to non-white or muslim people has
created the confidence that stuart
rhodes has that he will be able to go
all the way through trial turn it into a
circus get his name all over the media
and then walk away with his image
rejuvenated with the right wing
well i i think i think stuart is uh
completely dead wrong about that and i
think oh he's completely [ __ ]
yeah yeah i i think i think he's capital
f-u-c-k [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] because he's not
he's not just [ __ ] um in in the legal
trial but when we see what we're going
to see on january 6 because i would
suspect that the words oath keepers and
stuart rhodes name comes up several
times in the public hearings and it's
not going to be good for stewart and
it's not going to be good for anyone
who's associated
with those public hearings dakota
thank you for joining us again please
come back as these uh january 6 select
uh committee hearings develop as the
news with these oath keepers if we get
more plea deals from these oath keepers
um you know we we always appreciate your
insight not just into the news but also
into the mind and the culture of the
militia and what it means what it means
for
our our country like what what what is
it going to be if are we going to be
authoritarian are we not so i appreciate
you joining us thank you everyone stick
around we will be right back
after these messages buy the products
yeah
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for joining us thanks for
sticking around
gabe what an interview
yeah it's always great having to code on
yeah it's always a great time it's
always a great time having dakota on um
when he can come in and give us some
insight into stewart rhodes and the
brain of stuart rhodes more than
anything i think growing up with stewart
and having him around being kind of like
oath keeper junior you know like yeah
he's talked about in previous interviews
like that's how he was raised he was
raised around these militia groups he
knows these people uh from front
backwards inside and out yeah and he's
very much a uh an oath keeper whisperer
right exactly that's a good that's a
oath keeper whoo i just got chills whoo
gold keeper whisper yeah man
yeah keeper whisper code if you're
listening maybe we should give you a new
uh new nickname a new handle the oath
keys oath keeper whisper because dakota
has a uh has not just an insight into
stewart and the oath keepers but the
militia and that that whole movement
that whole culture right and i think um
you know we talked about there's a great
piece in the uh southern poverty law
center that they have and maybe we'll
post that link yeah yeah um on the pod
page after this that uh people can go
read it's about uh dakota and the family
uh you should definitely go give it a
give it a shout out there but dakota's
super smart and he knows this stuff and
and he not just has
the education of of the oath keeper
whisper as you'd as you said um but also
he's got a good handle on history and
what what it what it means
in this time
and the context of oath keepers in our
history yeah um in the in the
play-by-play so thank you dakota for
joining us come back uh anytime we
definitely need to have him on in the
next couple weeks with some of the new
updates oh yeah since since last weekend
yeah i mean yeah since we you know we as
i said on the call i was like literally
this breaking news of the buffalo
shooting happened
and that was saturday
and since then we've gotten an update in
terms of i think was yesterday or the
day before monday or tuesday we had an
update as term the court documents right
um you know we had seth macfarlane who
was covering the uh he was inside the
courtroom i believe i believe so but one
thing i want to do real
before we get too too heavy and i i want
to make sure we get to a couple videos
here oh yeah so let's well i promised
everyone after the interview we'd go to
the [ __ ] list rounded we have about 15
minutes so let's start doing a countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
the tony michaels podcast we've reached
the shitless round of finally gabe uh of
today this first video i want to show
you is um from david pepper's uh he's in
a small town in ohio we know that tim
ryan is one ohio and now we know uh
looks like uh fetterman is going to win
pennsylvania those two candidates are
going to be very very very similar
in the their ideology and how they're
going to run those campaigns i would
imagine
seeing that ohio and pennsylvania are
kind of like sister states there's a lot
of commonalities that those two states
have especially about their electorate
but let's listen to david here
midas robin sent this to me minus
robin's got a lot of alley-oops here
here yeah let's let's listen are you an
ohioan
are you appalled by what they are doing
to towns like this across ohio
left in decay
poverty abandonment broken windows empty
buildings i'm appalled by what they're
doing and who are they and what are they
doing
uh they are the republican state house
who for decades have engaged in trickle
down economics
uh pulling resources from communities
like this and giving them away to people
who are already doing very well in life
they've done that with local funds from
towns like this funds that were supposed
to be spent on local services like
police and fire have been ripped away
from towns like this for more than a
decade and given away as tax cuts at the
high end
so that
you know while they claim that democrats
are the ones defunding the police
all along it's been republicans for more
than a decade defunding police and other
local services from communities like
this
they've done the same thing for schools
they have rated school funds of millions
and millions of dollars and given those
monies to their donors to run online
for-profit charter school scams
all while local school funding and local
schools have suffered
again and again we see this pattern
under investment infrastructure
under investment in broadband
over and over again
while also their corporate backers have
also been
the ones who engaged in massive uh
expansion of pill mills and delivery
prescription drugs in a way that
decimated towns like this a decade ago
and these towns have never recovered
now what do they do when confronted with
these issues and and david's going to
make a good point here but i want to
stop because um
we've all seen towns like this in in
rural america if you've been driving out
there in in rural america um where you
drive through it's it's a little town
that looks like at one time it was a
bustling a little place to be but it's
no longer anymore there's no factory
there's no work there uh if there is
work there and it's minimum wage type
work and and and we we see we see what
he's gonna say here but we know what has
happened in some of these towns in
america and why they still support these
this authoritarian rule is because
people
when someone looks at you and says it's
the brown people doing this to you we
need to build a wall it's the corrupt
democrats that are doing this to you
it's her emails
what we need to do is we need to hire
one person one person that can wave a
magic wand and fix all of this for us
exactly that is the desire the
authoritarian rule because a lot of
times in these towns there's there's not
much more way they see out because they
don't see as the government and policy
as the thing that's going to fix this
thing they see that as the enemy the
government is the enemy the uh
the the politicians the elected
officials are the enemies what i need is
a king i need someone who's just gonna
come in and love me because i am who i
am and i'm not going anywhere and
they're gonna give it all back to us but
let's listen to what david says these
problems with this decay
first the state senator from this area
was asked what he would do to help and
he told the people this town to move but
secondly you see what we see in jd
vance's ads
they blame people from thousands of
miles away or they blame kids who may
identify differently than their kids or
blame professors at law schools for
teaching certain courses
as if that's the reason why towns like
this are failing no folks it's the
policies from places like the republican
state house that are failing the longer
we allow them to to shift the blame
and divert from their failures the
longer failures like those in this town
will continue and i think he makes a
great point there gabe in this video
that you can't just pay attention to
some of these national races you also
got to pay attention to some of these
state races because that some of that
policy comes down um is in these state
state and local races so people when
you're out there voting make sure you're
not just paying attention to who you're
the senate the national senate senate
candidate or the national congressional
candidate is but also who those local
who those local candidates are it's
super important i mean it's the same
reason that you have to make you have to
look out and be aware of those that are
running you know for the board of your
of your local school district or the you
know the people who are who are making
those those decisions on a micro level
um you have to consider that these
people are just getting their start in
those positions and are aspiring whether
it's their own or someone else who's
kind of pulling the strings uh for
further kind of advancement in another
more um
influential position uh on a on a state
or national
uh level so that is something to
remember too it's not just these big
elections you know like tony was saying
it's these smaller ones you know and as
well as david pepper here it is the
smaller ones that actually matter and
can you know
kind of trickle up
right to larger positions exactly benny
loco says time to take her back from the
orange cold i think you're giving the
country gender and i believe that the
country's gender would be a her for sure
because america rocks
and so do women um so uh i got another
video i want to show you here gabe as
we're running out of time but i want to
get to it um it's uh speaking of bigger
elections doctors have they have they uh
declared i haven't noticed have they
agreed on the winner yet i know there
was contention trump trump was on uh um
um uh tooth central the uh dentist
office over there at the dentist awful
social
media and he was saying dr oz should
just declare victories if that's how it
works but right i mean again you know
it's just one of those things where
trump is trying to push this
authoritarian is trying to push
uh so that his nominee can get through
especially if it's so close he's like
right i don't want it to be stolen i
don't know it's not it's not about dr oz
or republicans in general it's about him
not because he lost the cocktail and
race he lost the herbster race so he
doesn't want to lose this one let's get
this he goes if he goes oh for three i
think you know i think it's really fun i
think what people are realizing is
they're beginning to distance themselves
and it's becoming that maybe trump
doesn't have the influence that he once
had around this
uh insane republican party
and you never want to let your people
down so when you go to bed at night and
put your head on that soft pillow you
know oz will be doing exactly what you
want him to do if you were there next to
him what so he's saying dr oz is going
to be in bed with you this is really
[ __ ] weird listen like like yeah like
if yeah
please listen again listen again listen
closely and you never want to let your
people down so when you go to bed at
night put your head on that soft pillow
you know oz will be doing exactly what
you want him to do if you were there
next to him okay and i can't do these if
he's not why are they so [ __ ] good if
he i know if he is next to you in bed
one that is creepy two did he just break
in and enter into your home without sort
of any sort of consensus no what is it
that means that he wouldn't be doing his
job if he's in the bed with you right
next to you spooning with you like a
little creep
well i guess in many ways he would be
doing very much and following the same
tune of the republican party why it is
like going against your consent and
creeping on you regardless of who you
are but at the end of the day he would
just be in bed sleeping not doing his
job so i guess that's pretty accurate
speaking of creeps who like the sext a
lot apparently mark meadows has been
doing more sexting game you may you may
have more uh text messages really let's
let's listen let's listen to chief of
dumb [ __ ] here
i can't tell you this though uh uh
the the ultimate victor last night
across the country was was donald trump
contacted last night and again this
morning by two different candidates
saying how do i get the endorsement from
donald trump because it is magic uh
especially in this particular case where
mccormick outspent dr oz two to one none
of this none of this that he's saying is
true not yeah not him
candidates who are reaching out being
like oh man let me gargle the balls here
like right let's get trump on this
ticket like no uh and i also looked up
uh oz is currently ahead of mccormick
it's barely
to 30.1
it is reporting that uh oz has 412
995 and dave mccormick has 410
697. so we're looking at thousand
and uh
two hundred and ninety-eight it looks
like the difference between the two well
that's great
95
are greater than 95 so i'm sure that by
the end of the day we'll probably have
the final tally good good well uh
speaking of mccormick i have a clip of
mccormick here oh this is this is a
republican now remember how evil mail
and ballots are gabe like they're so old
we gotta be against them we have to ban
these mail-in ballots we had to ban
mail-in ballots more uh quickly than we
do abortions apparently but let's listen
to what david mccormick says here let's
listen to what he says
now we're gonna
we're gonna win this campaign we're
gonna win this campaign
and uh and tomorrow right now we have
tens of thousands
of mail-in ballots that have not been
counted that are going to need to be
counted beginning tomorrow
and uh and so that unfortunately we're
not going to have resolution tonight
but we can see the path ahead we can see
so
mccormick here is alluding to what
happens in pennsylvania so what happens
in pennsylvania is they don't actually
count the mail-in ballots the day of the
election they start counting those the
next day that's actually what happened
in pennsylvania during the 2020 election
they're like oh you can't count ballots
past midnight the ballots don't count
you know you remember because before
stop the steal
it was stopped to count because they
were like if you keep counting ballots
right joe biden's gonna win like that
was the whole fear and here we have
mccormick admitting that yeah you the
law of the pennsylvania law is that they
actually don't count the mail-in ballots
still
after you know dakota made a good point
during the interview which by the way i
thought was a great interview but he
made a good point during there he's like
if you don't pick a lane
then you're neither right or wrong right
but republicans though have clearly you
know they wanted to stop it the steel
they wanted to stop the count they you
know they had groups that were yelling
at different ends of the country
depending on how the outcome was looking
right you had arizona who wanted to
uh stop the steal right and then i think
people in pennsylvania wanted to stop
the count so it's like you have this
conflicting message that was happening
where they were like no keep counting no
stop counting no keep counting all right
it depends on where he was winning and
where he was exactly it's all it's all
continued on if he was winning or if he
was losing right in this scenario right
now again he's like oh i'm losing so
every [ __ ] vote counts now we're
gonna we're gonna count all the ballots
all of the mail-in ballots so don't be
surprised that if tomorrow comes around
after we've counted these ballots i
might be out in the head okay because
counting does matter though we are
trying to get rid of counting in schools
right right yeah math sucks well
speaking of both sides of the fence um
at least star phonic excuse me stefanik
who wants to starve children at the
border because she's pro-life um here's
here's her statement on the
mass uh the manga king mass shooter in
buffalo um i call him the maga king mass
shooter because that's what he is and
elise stefanik here is trying to both
sides of the fence the buffalo shooter
she loves him because he believes in her
white replacement therapy but she hates
him because she makes her look bad and
makes her uh the victim here because of
politics let's listen into what this
[ __ ] has to say i want to take a
moment my home state new york our nation
is heartbroken and saddened of the
horrific loss of life in buffalo this
was an act of pure evil and the criminal
should be prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law i don't believe her it
is not the time to politicize this
tragedy we mourn together as a nation
it it she doesn't look i don't i don't
think she actually she's not telling us
no not at all like why why would they
have her go out like if if they were
like hey hey you really gotta sell this
and she's like i don't know if i can i
mean i'm really distraught that people
are claiming really actually support
what this guy was saying right like i s
i was saying it out loud and by the way
by the way not only do i believe that
there's white replacement that the wrt
the white replay which is all [ __ ]
right
white replacement therapy but i all
therapy jesus christ theory i mean
that's what it is right it's
indoctrination to say that white people
deserve you know yeah right but here's
here's the thing she also says those
brown kids those brown kids down at the
border because they're coming across boy
they don't deserve nutrition [ __ ] em
starve em and that is that literally
she has rolled up in and so little bow
and chris cute little bow here of the
current gop the current gqp the fascist
party the ninja poop nazis that are the
republicans in this country so remember
remember now is the time to make your
outrage outrage count so go [ __ ] vote
and listen to our podcast every single
weekday
eastern 11 central nine pacific youtube
twitter twitch and now simulcasting from
the midas touch facebook page
until tomorrow the same time same place
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking